derniers ajustements sur l'une des trois
stations météo installée par
l'association sxm cyclone avec ces
capteurs philippe mollé peut suivre en
temps réel les vents les précipitations
et les impacts de foudre
ces données sont ensuite collectées et
transmises aux autorités soit par
exemple les collectivités préfecture
pour le classement en catastrophe
naturelle mais aussi distribuée au nhs à
météo france sur demande
cette nouvelle station est installé sur
le toit de l'aéro club de martinique et
enfin mettre un petit coup d'oeil sur la
gauche
ce passionné de météo doit encore
contrôler la réception des données un
outil très pratique pour les pilotes du
club
on s'est régalé conditions des vents
d'élections pour les différents
exercices qu'on va faire avec notre
célèbre pour ses informations sont
également accessibles aux particuliers
sur le site de sxm cyclone est justement
le passage d'une onde tropicale permet
de tester le dispositif
ici on a tous les impacts en cours on
quand on s'éloigne ça permet d'avoir un
nombre d'impacts il suffit de cliquer
dessus
on va repérer ces impacts là où ils sont
sur le site nous les transformant en
georges d'affichage manière ça soit
visuel et ça soit des ronds avec des
valeurs ce qui permet comme ça aux gens
d'avoir une idée du temps et surtout du
vent la pression et ainsi de suite
en direct ces informations sont ensuite
mises en réseau par les élèves du bts
systèmes numériques du lycée joseph
gaillard nos projets informatiques
enfants deuxième année sont
systématiquement partenariats avec des
entreprises donc comme c'est le cas ici
et donc on fait en sorte justement que
ça puisse avoir un débouché quelconque
après quand ils sont en situation de
recherche d'emploi alors que le ciel est
dégagé
la station de saint martin enregistre
les premiers impacts de foudre des
données précieuses pour le nhc américain
chargé de prévoir les système cyclonique
dans la zone atlantique